salut c'est monsieur on parle beaucoup
d'apple on parle beaucoup des iphone à
venir parce que c'est un sujet assez
passionnant apple influence énormément
le marché de la téléphonie mobile avec
ses modèles l'année dernière avec
l'iphone dit s'ils ont réellement
influencer énormément de modèles qui
sont sortis cette année en 2018 et
justement j'ai une idée et je vous faire
participer
je vous en parle
et
j'ai fait beaucoup de vidéo qui vous
parle de rumeurs des analyses faites par
des analystes justement plutôt bien
informés dans la place au sujet d'apple
est justement cette fois ci je ne compte
pas les choses sous un angle un petit
peu différent au lieu de vous parler de
ce que j'ai pu glaner comme information
à droite à gauche et d'en faire le
relais voulez vous nous disiez vous ce
que vous voudriez sur ses iphone de 2018
quelles sont vos attentes
dites moi quel design vous voulez est ce
que vous voulez qu'ils aient toujours
l'encoche oui non est ce que vous voulez
dans koch un peu plus petite alfa sont
de celles présentes sur le mât de plus
si ce qu'est ce que vous voulez en
termes de performance qu'est ce que vous
voulez au nombre de rames qu'est ce que
vous voulez en termes de stockage
l'écran quelle taille d'écran vous
voulez durera probablement plusieurs
iphone cette année qu'est ce que vous
voulez comme taille d'écran des écrans
plus petits des écrans plus grands
qu'est ce que vous voulez lcd oled
qu'est ce que vous voulez comme techno
derrière priziac pas deux prises jack
est ce que vous voulez toujours qu'il
adaptateur lightning priziac inclus dans
la boîte toujours fait side et le retour
du bouton ou alors carrément pourquoi
pas un capteur d'empreintes digitales
directement intégré à l'écran et pour la
photo est ce que vous vous êtes toujours
le double module photo à la verticale à
l'arrière ou alors pourquoi pas comme
huawei un trip capteur photo ou alors
pourquoi pas comme samsung une lentille
à ouverture variable pour vraiment
optimisé en faible luminosité
pour la vidéo est secouée du super slow
motion pourquoi pas du 1080p en 960
images par seconde
il ya toutes ces données techniques
toutes ces infos qu'est ce que vous
voulez comme couleur quelle forme
voulait qu'il est voilà vous vous lâchez
vous marquez tout ça en commentaire vous
le dis tout ce que vous voulez qu'elle
serait l'iphone
idéal pour vous cette année qu'est ce
que vous voudriez retrouver en termes de
prix qu'est ce que vous attendez d'apple
cette année et clou du spectacle une
fois que j'ai récupéré toutes ses infos
toutes vos données chez faire un tri je
vais sortir les grandes tendances le
portrait-robot type de ce que vous
attendez vous comme iphone pour cette
année et ensuite on va l'envoyer apple
alors je doute qu'apple en prennent note
mais malgré tout on va le renvoyer
donc marquer moi tout ça directement en
commentaire on a dressé le portrait
robot de ce que devrait être selon nous
selon vous l'iphone dès mai 18 à les y a
vous de jouer et on se retrouve d'ici
quelques jours pour en reparler et on
fera un super débriefer à mon avis n'est
pas au bout de nos surprises d'ici là
soyez sages laissez-moi des jolies
pouces abonnez vous et à très bientôt
ciao